foreign
have you ever wondered how facial
recognition works on social media or how
object detection helps in building
self-driving cars it is all possible
thanks to convolutional neural network
CNN hello everyone I am mayank and
welcome to Simply learn today we will
take you through our hands of lab demo
of how we can use CNN model for image
classification in machine learning for
amazing videos like this subscribe to
our YouTube channel and press that Bell
icon to stay updated in today's session
we will discuss what CNN model is and
moving ahead we will discuss how does
CNN recognize images after that we will
see layers in CNN at the end we will do
a hands of layer demo of image
classification using CNN in fact its
study says there will be more than 2.3
million job openings in field of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning by 2023 but you can beat the
curve with our professional certificate
programming Ai and machine learning
co-sponsored by Purdue University and
IBM which is designed after simply learn
intense bootcamp learning model Ai and
ml certification code this course covers
tools and techniques like python
tensorflow Keras nltk and many more
along with industry projects like social
media by Twitter delivery service
provider by zomato transportation
service provided by Uber and many more
Amazing projects choosing this course
can you get hired by renowned companies
like Google Amazon LinkedIn and Adobe
and an average salary hike of 70 percent
so what are you waiting for join the AI
and Ms professional certificate program
and actually your career in artificial
intelligence and machine learning the
link is in description box below before
we move on to the programming part let's
discuss what CNN is and proceed for the
for the same what is CNN a convolutional
neural network is a feed forward neural
network that is generally used to
analyze visual images by processing data
with grid like topology it is also known
as convenient a conventional neural
network is used to detect and classify
objects in an image so this is a neural
network that identifies two types of
flowers or jit and Rose in CNN every
image is represented in the form of an
array or pixel here you can see it is a
real image of Digit 8 and it is
represented in the form of an array and
here 0 represent negative values and
what represent positive values okay it's
creating eight here so digit 8 represent
in the form of pixels of zeros and ones
so now let's understand the convolution
you're operating using two matrices A
and B of one dimension now let's
understand the convolution operations
using two matrices A and B of one
dimension
a equals to five three two five nine
seven b equals to one two three so in
convolutional operation the arrays are
multiply element wise and the product is
sum to the create a new array which
represent a into B so here
a into B five three two and one two
three multiply the arrays element wise
and this is the sum of the product so
the first three element of the Matrix a
are multiplied with the elements of
Matrix B and the product is sum to the
get the result so a into B is 17. the
next three element from The Matrix a are
multiplied by the element in the Matrix
B and the product is summed up so here
some of the product is 22 so a into B is
17 and 22. this process continues until
the convolution operation is complete so
moving forward now let's discuss how
does CNN recognize images so consider
following these images the boxes that
are color represent a pixel value of 1
and 0 if not colored when you press
backslash The below image get processed
and when you press the forward slash the
below images process here is another
example to depict how CNN recognize an
image
so consider this is a real image
now it is represented in the forms of
black and white pixels and this image
represents in the form of Matrix of
number here you can see where here the
black part and here is one value
so it's creating the image image
represented in the forms of Matrix of
numbers so as you can see from this
diagram only those values are lit that
have value of 1 okay this is how the CNN
recognize the images now moving forward
let's see layers in convolution neural
network CNN a convolution neural address
has multiple hidden layers that help in
extracting information from an image the
four important layers in CNN are first
is convolution layer second is cooling
layer third is Prelude layer and fourth
is fully connected layer so now let's
start with convolution layer
so this is the first step in the process
of extracting valuable features from an
image a conventional layer has several
filters that perform the convolution
operations every image is considered as
a matrix of pixel value so consider this
the following five into five image whose
pixel values are either 0 or 1. there is
also a filter Matrix with a dimension of
three by three slider filter Matrix over
the image and compute the dot product to
get the convolved feature Matrix and the
second is relu layer relu performs an
element wise operation and sets all the
negative pixel to zero it introduce
non-linearity to the network and the
generated output is an rectified feature
map So Below is the graph of radio
function so the original image is
scanned with a multiple convolution and
radio layers for locating the features
like this relu layers create the feature
Maps like this and after that
input feature map creates
the rectified feature map
this is how black negative is the wide
non-negative values
or positive values you can see so it
will create the rectified feature map
really layers so now third layer comes
into the action pooling layer so pooling
layer pooling is a down sampling
operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map the
rectified feature map now goes through a
pooling layer to generate a pool feature
map so this is a rectified feature map
so here are three four one two from this
it will take the maximum value here here
is 4 and from this it will take the
maximum value 7. and from this it will
take the 8 and 6 okay so max pooling
with two by two filters and this is the
stride two the Boolean layers uses
various filter to identify different
parts or images like edges corners body
feathers eyes and Beak as you can see
from the pictures so now let's see how
the structure of CNN looks so far hence
the diagram represents the structure of
CNN so far so the next step is a process
is called flattening this is called the
flattening process so flattening is used
to convert all the resultant two
dimensional array from pole feature Maps
into a single long continuous linear
Vector so as you can see it is a pool
feature map after flattening it converts
into single long continuous linear
vector the flattened Matrix is fed as
input to the fully connected layer to
classify the images so this is CNN here
comes the relu then pooling then it is
the input to the final layer after this
so input image then convolutional layer
then relu layers comes in then pooling
layer then flattening now this is fully
connected layer which is CNN this is how
the CNN grade after connecting the three
layers relu convolutional and pulling
layers so this is how exactly does CNN
recognize images okay the pixel from the
image are fed to the convolutional layer
that perform the convolution operations
here then it results in a convolved map
the control map is applied to relu
function here the control map applied to
relay function to generate a rectified
feature map here it creates the Rectify
feature map and the image is processed
with multiple convolution and radio
layers for locating the features then
different pooling layers with various
filter are used to identify specific
parts of the image here the max pooling
does so the pool features is flattened
and fed to fully connected layers to get
this is the
flat end fat to pulley connected layers
this is a fully connected layer and that
is how it got the final output bird okay
this is a feature extraction in multiple
written layers classification the output
layer so now moving forward let's start
the programming part so here so this is
the python kernel file
so here first we will
change the name CNN
CNN
the thickness
okay
yeah
so first we will import some major
libraries of python so I will write
import
numpy
s m b
then I run import
and import
matplotlib
dot Pi plot
as PLT
import c bond
as SNS
then import
Keras
after that import
tensorflow
Dot Keras so number is a python Library
used for working with arrays it also has
a function for working in the domain of
lineal algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely then by stand for numerical
Python and the second one is pandas
pandas is a software Library written for
the Python programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data structure and operations
for manipulating numerical tables and
Time series
and the third one is matplotlib so for
Python and its medical extension number
lib
is a cross-platform data visualization
and graphical charting package as a
result is represent a strong open source
substitute for Matlab and the API
application programming interfaces for
matplotlib allows programmers to
incorporate graphs into GI applications
and the fourth one is C bone C bone is a
python data visualization Library based
on mat problem it provides a high level
interface for drawing attractive and
informative statical Graphics from brief
introduction to ideas behind the library
you can read the introductory notes for
the people
is an open source software library that
provides a python interface for
artificial neural network Keras actors
interface for the tensorflow library up
until version 2.3 KRS supported multiple
backends include intensive flow
Microsoft cognitive toolkit piano and
plate ML and the fourth one is
tensorflow tensorflow is a free and open
source software library for machine
learning and artificial intelligence it
can be used across a range of tasks but
has a particular focus on training and
inference of deep lunar letter
okay
so here we are going to load data first
let me write line
extreme
comma y train
comma
X test
comma y test
equals to klas Dot
data sets
dot fashion
mnisd
dot load
data
okay so there are 10 different classes
of images funny like t-shirt or trouser
pullover dress code sandal shirt sneaker
back ankle boot and the image that I
mentioned are 28 by 28. so in this we
are splitting the data into training and
testing set so what is mnisd
so fashion mnisd consists of 60 000
training images and 10 000 testing
images it is mnst like fashion product
database the developers believe mnst has
been overused so they create this as a
direct replacement for the data set
each image is in grayscale and
associated with the label from 10
classes each image is 28 pixel in height
and 28 pixel in weight for a total of
784 pixels in total so each pixel has a
single Pixel value associated with it
indicating the lightning or darkness of
that pixel with higher number meaning
darker the pixel value is then integer
between 0 and 255 so moving forward we
will see that how much data we have in
training and the resting so here I will
write X train
dot shape
there is no need I guess
or this
comma
y train
or tape
okay
see we have 60 000
rows and 28 columns for a particular
data set
okay
now
X
test dot shape
comma y
test dot a
error in the testing we have 10 000 rows
and 28 columns I already told you before
when I talked about the data set like we
have 60 000 training images at that 10
000 testing images
okay
so
and if you want this full code I will
provide you in the description box below
just comment for the same that you want
the full code okay so now let's train
the data
then X
train
the label y
y
and let's see this
so what I will do with better visuals I
will do like this so now let's see for
the show images so here I will set the
class labels
class
tables
t-shirt
t-shirt or it can be top
okay then trousers
and
pull over
dress
then quote
then standard
but
because
then
back
Englewood
let's see some images
so what
yeah
I will write class
um
I will write BLT dot show
X strain
command C map
let's show
great
you see it is a ankle boot let's look
like an anchor board
let's see one more
ftlt dot I am sure
strain
emap
equals to
Grace
okay it is a t-shirt
we have 60 000 images in the trading set
so we can check the any
let's see one more PLT dot I am show
strain
.
just to Grace
there's a shoe
okay let's copy it
the last we are checking
for the 50.
something dress
okay
so this is that for the training that is
why we are writing here extreme
right
so
now let's see the all the categories
okay like sneaker ankle boot code and
t-shirt okay
sandal and all
so for that I will write here PLT Dot
figure
size
I will give 16 by 16.
okay
equals to 1
for I
n
NP dot random
Dot
and
0 comma
ten thousand
thirty thousand only twenty five
elt dot subplot
F comma five
comma J
Plus
two one
PLT dot I am sure
X string
I
my cmapped
equals to what Grace
okay
then PFD dot X is
of
and PLT dot title
again calibrances
but I will write here
Dot format
as
well
by train
one
y train
okay so now let's see run it
okay so there is an error
object has no property cap okay
it is cmap
okay now you can see the sneaker bag
pullover sandal dress
so all the categories okay short code
bag sticker this is for the training the
trousers we are
training all the images
okay for the model
so now what we will do we will reshape
some
training data
okay the length and the testing data
length
so moving forward we will do that
let's
do
reshaping and on
so fashion
um
equals to
KRS dot data sets
dot passion
right here
X strain
a y train
comma
X test
was so
fashion
extreme
this dimensions
so here I will write X strain
minus one
okay or we can write X strain equals to
Extended reshape length x strip
okay
uh here I will write X test
equals to NP Dot expand
dimensions
X test
comma minus one
okay here I will let
a one
plus two
NP dot add a
D dot unique
a train
equals to
and here I will write
for
uh
hit one
then EA index
one
dot append
append to list
y train
Dot
index
I
okay then print
X
one
okay so cross check for I in index print
white and I okay so here I will write
PLT dot figure
because size
24 comma twenty four
okay four
X comma y
and
enumerate
index one
this
and I will add print
extreme
dot shape
then PLT dot subplot
2 comma five
comma
X plus one
LT dot I am show
tensorflow
who is
and X strain
y
equals to Grace
PhD Dot title
dot com format
K1
thanks
okay X strain and P dot index
would expand
hips X strain minus one
okay
valid index
what I wrote here let me check
import numpy as NP
the errors
okay let me check the other
working
these are the 10 category
okay
these are the pixel size
28 into 28
okay
so moving forward what we will do we
will change the dimensions
okay and then after that we will do the
feature scaling
okay for the changing dimension
we'll do X string
dot end
S three dimension image this one is the
three dimensional image
then X strain dot shape
is 60 000 then what I will do
strain
equals to NP
Dot
expand
in
comma minus 1.
just
for sure
NP dot expand
test comma
minus one
so four dimension image X
strain
m
okay
and dim
this is a four dimension image okay the
next
chain
or shape
okay fine
so now what we will do we will do the
feature scaling
so for the features killing I will write
here x strain
equals to
X strain
by 255.
okay
here I will write X test question
X test
bye
so what is feature scaling feature
scaling is the method used to normalize
the range of independent variables or
features of the data so in data
processing it is also known as the data
normalization
and is generally performed during the
data pre-processing steps
okay
so
let's see the data is in 0 to 1 for that
right here
small small code X strain
in
to you
so now what we will do we will split the
data set for the validation set
okay for that we will write here from
SK learn
dot model
selection
import
then
Trust
it strain
go
X
value
comma y train
y value
let's do train
test
spirit
and here I will write dentist split then
okay
split then I will write here
X strain
comma y train
test
over here now I will write X strain
dot shape
by train
shape
8000 okay then x value
dot shape
comma y value
oh
okay 12 000. see our total
images in extreme were sixty thousand so
now we'll do we did the train touch
split okay so test size is 0.2 so we're
split into like 80 and 20
okay
so that is why there are 48 000 images
so now we'll make
CNN model okay convolutional neural
network so for the convolutional front
end we can start with the like three
conversion layer with a small filter
size and modest number of filters okay
followed by a Max pooling layer the
filter Maps can be the flattened to
provide features to the classifier okay
so
we know that we required an output layer
with like 10 nodes in order to predict
the probability distribution of an image
belonging to each of the 10 classes this
is also require use of sort Max
activation function between the feature
extractor and the output layer
we can add a dense layer to interpret
the feature in this case with the 128
nodes
okay so listen that like all layers will
use the relu activation function and the
weight initialization scheme like both
best practices
what we will do we will
create
model
okay
so
so this is the code
for the model
okay so in this we use the layers these
are the three layers layer one layer 2
layer three okay
so as I said to you we will start from
the max pouring layer
okay
so
here we used units equals to 128. and
activation equals to relu
okay
and there is dance Dance Again the layer
so
Max pooling here is a term Max pulling
2D so it is a pooling or Max pooling
operation which calculates the largest
or the maximum value in every patch and
and in the every features
okay
so it is used in the pooling operation
that calculates the maximum value for
the patches
and to create the pool feature map
got it
and here is a dance
so dance is like in any neural network a
dense layer is a layer that is deeply
connected with the presenting preceding
layer so which means the neurons of the
layer are connected to every neuron of
its preceding layer the layer is mostly
commonly used in artificial neural
network
okay
and there is
dropouts like
how much
it will be drop out for every
you know layers from every layers
there is one more word
Clayton so flattening is used to convert
all the resultant two dimensional array
from pool feature map into a single long
continuous linear vector
the flattened Matrix is fed as input to
the fully connected layer to the
classify image
okay
and this soft Max is a like equation
or a function you used to activation
function in the output layer of the
neural network
and
that predictor multinomiality
probability distribution that is soft
Max is used as the activation function
okay
and relu is again
you know a particular layer
forward
the visuals
so now what we will do we will plot the
neural network for the workflow
okay
Keras
Dot
else
dot modern
Dot
PNG
X
happening
sure
oops
question
true
yeah I will write so
layer
custom
true
there is an error
okay
model is not defined so what we have to
do
we have to install here Pi Dot
okay pip install Pi Dot
and install graph with
okay so let me install and let I will
come back to you so
here what I will write we'll see the
model dot summary
this is the model summary
okay
and now what we will do we will compile
and model fitting do the model fitting
so here I will do the model Dot
compile
optimizer
plus two
atom
categorical
cross
trophy
okay
here I will add Matrix
question
curacy
okay
so now I will write model Dot fit
right here
let me delete this
order Dot
it
extreme
um
train
comma a box
equals to
more batch
size
equals to Pi 1 2
oh my wordpose
plus two one
comma
validation
data
equals to X
well
comma y
okay
so it will take time it will run till 94
okay the law is the accuracy will come
so we have to wait for some more minutes
till let it be complete
it will
be Hotel 20
so I will get back to you when it will
be complete
almost 14 done 15 16 17 18 19 20 are
left
so we'll wait and we'll see
so any POG is when all the training data
is used at once and is defined as a
total number of iteration of all the
training data in one cycle for the
training and machine learning model so
another way to define a book is the
number of passes a training data set
takes around an algorithms
okay
will wait till 20
more left
yeah the laws accuracy and validation
laws
value loss
if you want this full code you can
comment and if you have been query
related to python machine learning or
anything
okay you can comment down
our team will
reach you as soon as possible
so
two more 19 and 20.
raise your model accuracy is good 93
if you have any query you can comment
down below
okay 19 is done
final 20 is going on epoch
you can enroll in our
course of AI and ml you can check the
link in the description box below
using course
after this we will test the model then
we will do evaluation
then confusion messed tricks and then
visualization of the output the final
output
okay
yeah so it's done so now let's test the
model testing of the model
so now let's start the testing the model
okay
so here I will write
model dot predict
Dot
expand
okay
X
test
at zero axis
round is how many decimal points okay
so now
NP dot ARG Max
and
model
dot predict
NP dot expand
times
X test
this will be zero
[Music]
this will be 0
.
dot round
added two
okay
excess
not okay
so here I have to write x equals to zero
okay
so now cross check
why test
zero
you see him
okay
then
y
prediction
equals to model
dot predict
then
accessed
to
prediction
so now we will evaluate so model Dot
evaluate
dot evaluate
test
comma y
oh now let's do the model evaluation
so accuracy given by train set is 0.94
which is very good 94 and accuracy given
by test set is 90 so thus we can say
that our model is generalized so no
overlifting or not underfitting okay so
now confusion metrics
so from SK learn
Dot
Matrix
port
confusion
Matrix
okay then PLT Dot
figure
then figure size
let's do
16 comma nine
underscore prediction
by prediction
plus u n p Dot
ARG Max
label
or
label and
y prediction
then cm
conversion Matrix equals to
confusion
tricks
I test
I
prediction
labels
okay
so
now
we will write
my will create heat map SNS Dot
heat map
Vision metrics
comma a naught
was true true
then fmt
equals to
d
comma
X stick
labels
so
class
dot labels
then
why tick
level
was so
class levels
okay
there's another
foreign
dress coat and hair also
okay
so
now
we will visualize the output
so PLT dot so it is like coming correct
or not okay expected and predicted okay
or you can say the actual and predicted
so PLT dot figure
bigger size
plus two
sixteen comma 30
equals to 1
or I
and NP Dot
random
Dot
pendant
comma
60.
PLT dot subplot
X
comma
okay
then here I will write J plus 1
equals to one
and PLT Dot
I am sure
X
test
I
e shape
it's 28 height and width
and cmap equals to Grace
PLT dot access
of
PLT dot title
here
right
equals to
okay
slash n
addicted
pursue
dot format
Us labels
my test
all right
Max
bye
dictate is I
then will write NB Dot
ARG Max
I
predicted
press enter
loading
so
as you can see actually T-shirt shop
t-shirt and top then predicted you also
find
okay some error then trousers are same
sandals are same ankle boot also same
so as you can see here
some are right and some are wrong
because the testing accuracy is 90 the
predicted accuracies that the training
accuracy is 94 that is why okay
so this is
the CNN of image classification how you
can use
and if you have any queries related any
code or you want this full code you can
ask me in the comment section okay I
will provide you the full code so mostly
the related and actual are coming till
then everything is coming good so I hope
you guys understand till here if you
have any question or any query regarding
any code a question just put us in
comments our team will surely provide
you the correct solution
so I hope you guys have much understood
the concept of CNN what is CNN what is
how CNN recognized images
and
that thing so
thank you so much for being here if you
enjoyed this video please do subscribe
to our YouTube channel and give a like
to this video till then thank you and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here